when was the last time you moved did you
become a refugee an immigrant or a word
on a tea party protest sign maybe not
but get this at least 232 million people
around the world that's over 3 percent
of the global population are living in
countries they weren't born in or aren't
citizens of the United Nations called
them international migrants every year
millions migrate legally and also
legally voluntarily and not so
voluntarily why here are the three major
reasons the world is moving in
unprecedented numbers it's a sad fact
but war and persecution aren't going
anywhere anytime soon
and that means there's always going to
be people trying to escape it
not everyone fleeing war is legally
considered a refugee but many are the
biggest refugee communities right now
come from Afghanistan Somalia and most
recently Syria Pakistan Kenya and
Lebanon have all taken in the biggest
numbers of these refugees despite
serious challenges in Lebanon nearly one
in five people is now a Syrian refugee
Lebanon's infrastructure and economy
have been pushed to the breaking point
all this while developed countries in
the world have only taken in 14% of the
world's refugees does that sound fair to
you but the world's wealthiest countries
are taking in people looking for better
economic opportunities or just a better
life more than 2/3 of the world's
migrants live in high-income countries
and more migrants end up in the United
States than in any other country in the
world eleven point seven million people
born in Mexico now live in the u.s. one
reason higher wages compensation in the
u.s. for a single manufacturing job is
six times higher than it is in Mexico
and it's not just the West attracting
folks one big migration trend has people
from South Asia moving to the oil-rich
Gulf in the United Arab Emirates Indians
Bangladeshis and Pakistanis make up 90%
of the private workforce despite poor
working conditions unfair treatment and
low wages the last major force driving
people out of their homes the
environment most natural disasters like
floods hurricanes and earthquakes caused
internal displacement within a country
but sometimes nature actually pushes
people to cross borders a drought in the
Horn of Africa
more than 83,000 Somalis to flee to
Kenya in the first half of 2011 alone
natural disasters aside the changing
climate is also a factor in Tuvalu a
tiny island nation in the Pacific rising
sea levels are forcing people to move to
nearby countries like New Zealand so
from man-made to nature made those are
the three big reasons why global
migration is here to stay and
considering the UN calls movement a
human right to borders be a bit more
flexible let us know what you think by
tweeting us at aj+